welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for avatar 2 the way of water a
franchise says it's become a bit of a
punch line on some corners of the
internet but after seeing this trailer
on an imac screen in front of
multi-person madness i cannot wait to
revisit pandora as it explores its
oceanic region even if i myself fear the
open ocean because of you know the
sunlight and the voices i hear whenever
i stare at it for too long
even though this trailer is more vibes
than like easter eggs i still want to
break it down frame by frame for all the
cool attention to detail already present
in all this footage it looks amazing so
let's go
[Music]
the trailer opens in pandora's floating
hallelujah mountains or the aymarama
lusting
butchered the pronunciation but it is a
made-up language the big floaty rocks
you know suspended in the flux vortex
due to the meissner effect we see three
young navi trot out led by a human male
this is actually jack champion as javier
spider socorro a teenager born in the
human base of pandora hell's gate
rescued and adopted by jake and terry he
has to wear an oxygen mask of course now
following him are his navi siblings born
to jake and the teary their sons natayam
and loac and the eight-year-old daughter
tuck tiri or tuck i cannot get enough of
the music in this trailer composed by
simon franklin colleague to 2009 avatar
composer the great james horner the guy
behind the music of titanic and a number
of great movies who tragically died in a
plane crash in 2015 but this music is
just beautiful just three simple notes
repeating again and again followed by
the navi vocals of
music is simple just enough to transport
us to this gorgeous setting without
giving away too much like this whole
trailer does then we get a close-up of
natiiri as her face passes beneath the
light and shadows of the plant life it's
not just the skin texture in here it's
the use of light across different
textures and planes of her face her
eyelashes casting micro shadows on her
eyelids the way the light catches the
left eye eyelashes while the rest of the
eye is in shadow just to give the face
some dimension those eyelashes poking
out at you and just a smart move to have
the shadows move across the face to
highlight all the different parts of it
i mean not to sound like an avatar stan
the franchise definitely doesn't need me
to defend it i'm just saying that
there's a lot of artistry in the vfx
design it's not just a technology that's
the design that's the reason this movie
broke records and the reason why i'm so
excited for this next one now remember
the first film ended with jake stepping
up as the leader of the omatakaya clan
alongside moat permanently fusing his
human consciousness with this navi
avatar body and now 14 years later
jake's family flies to a new region of
pandora an ocean reef called met kaina
with a wholly different culture to it
notice jake no longer wears the
holoitcon collar nor his chest band
which might suggest a collapse or a
disbanding of that clan moving on
[Music]
so the family approaches the new meccana
region the trees showing their roots
exposed and those roots forming the
ground terrain that this new culture
walks upon much like the tree of souls
it's just a cool way of showing how all
the biodiversity of this planet is
connected but unlike the rainforest
setting this interconnectivity isn't
hidden or buried but exposed for the
world to see and i love how the curves
of those roots create tidal pools for
those navi to hang out in now it looks
like we can see six navi of this family
in flight tuck doubled up with one of
her family members meanwhile the adopted
human son spider is not visible among
them maybe he got captured and maybe
that's why they're seeking help or they
might have him tucked away so the met
kyna clan doesn't freak out when they
see him either way it seems like a big
conflict to this movie might be the
guardianship in custody over this human
sun one met kaina navi blows a conch
shell to announce their arrival and then
we see kate winslet as a new member of
this clan a free diver named ronal
apparently one reason for the delays was
the motion capture technology didn't
work underwater as well so they had to
invent a whole new technology to do it
winslet reportedly broke a record in one
of these diving tanks holding her breath
for seven minutes for one take i love
the updated physique of the aquatic
variant of the navi including more
muscular tails used for swimmings and
flattened upper arms wrists and hands
more adept for paddling moving on
[Music]
so we're seeing some new human
developments on the planet by the rda
mining corporation and their never
ending pursuit for the unobtainium we
can see a spider droid in the foreground
all this tech reminded me so much of
james cameron's technology and aliens
like the lifter we see a human in the
exoskeleton guiding two navi and
military fatigue one of them we could
see clearer in other shots notice that
dragon tattoo on his arm folks this is
the respawn form of colonel miles
quadrich stephen lang's villain from the
2009 film who yeah died but james
cameron has said that he will return the
process that he didn't want to reveal
just yet meanwhile the other na'vi
marine behind him i'm pretty sure is
corporal lyle waynflete matt gerald's
character who also died in the 2009 film
so either the quattridge human form who
died was himself an avatar being
remotely operated which would be nuts or
some new technology allows for human
consciousness and memories to be
detached from the body and remotely
stored and then re-uploaded a new form
something like we've seen in westworld
or black mirror altered carbon either
way now quattric is a navi and the
helicopters they pilot are equipped with
these windows that look resistant to
navi arrows which should definitely be
an upgrade after we saw those arrows
being so effective taking out the pilots
in the 2009 film but this video was
brought to you by the ridge the ridge
wallet is light sleek and industrial
it's designed to fit in your front
pocket unlike those bulky monstrosities
that make a sit crooked when they're in
our back pockets the ridge comes in over
30 styles and colors including carbon
fiber and burnt titanium it holds up to
12 cards and still has room for cash so
you can show up your fancy euro
collection to cashiers and other people
who probably don't care every ridge
wallet comes with a lifetime guarantee
and they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it they also have
great backpacks phone cases and other
cool gear so get 10 off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to ridge.com new rockstars that's
ridge.com new rockstars and use code new
rockstars find the link in the video's
description moving on to the next
section
[Music]
i know one thing
wherever we go
this family okay we see we're all diving
with a sub-aquatic species and you can
actually see where that species tendril
is tethered to her they're both so happy
then we see the family wading into a
part of the met kyano home that has its
own flux vortex effect and i just love
how the curves of the rocks match the
curves of the gas giant planet
polyphemus that pandora orbits as a moon
and you can see the star alpha centauri
a beyond that planet who knows maybe
there's a richer source of unobtainium
in the ocean floor beneath this wreath
and that's why the rda is targeting them
then we see this ceremonial ritual
including the members of the met kaina
wearing special ceremonial garb
including its chief tonowari and the
pregnant reia as it looks like the ewa
are in the roots in the water surface
below glowing i like how all the members
of this tribe are carrying their flames
in these curved shells then in a
floating rda facility spider and it
looks like jake jump in the water notice
how spiders wearing a life jacket poor
kid cannot swim meanwhile the navi form
of quattric turns around in anger i just
love that with this guy even as a nami
he keeps his marine haircut high and
tight i know one thing wherever i go
this haircut is my fortress on to the
last clip
[Music]
here's our fortress
so it looks like some battle is gonna go
down in this ocean region large plumes
of smoke rise as jake consoles his sons
meanwhile nati and tuck escape a
flooding facility oh james cameron
whether it's titanic or the abyss this
guy just loves staging crises in a
flooding tunnel and i always eat it up
then another shot of the met kaina
tomori and rhea followed by jake burying
a human firearm but attached to a
handmade strap i assume this is all part
of another battle between the navi and
the rda forces now we learned that edie
falco is going to be joining this cast
as general admir the new head of the
rda's interests meanwhile sigourney
weaver is also going to return in some
unknown role now grace also died in the
2009 film but you know if quattridge can
return so too can grace after her death
the trailer ends with the one line of
dialogue in this movie jake talking
about family being their fortress
underlying the universal themes of
family and what that really means it
seems like this movie's going to deal a
lot with interracial adoption something
that will be under threat in this movie
and definitely worth fighting for now
remember that the ua life forms are not
native to pandora they came here from
another world which is pretty clever
world building by james cameron for that
first film proving that there are new
vast horizons to explore beyond avatar 2
the way of water coming december 2022 we
got avatar 3 the seed bearer coming
december 2024 avatar 4 the token writer
could be december 2026 and avatar 5 the
quest for yua coming december 2028 2028
what a concept you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos be sure
to follow new rockstars check out all of
our great merch options over at
nrockstarsmerch.com subscribe to
rockstars here on youtube for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you